das Saint-God-Hard-Massiv war einst
das größte Hindernis zwischen Nord-
und Südeuropa der Berg war eine
Barriere für Menschen und Waren, die
mühsam überwunden werden musste
[Musik]
heute ist es einfach, das
Mauseloch mitten im Berg
zu durchqueren  als wäre das tal
durch den fels verlängert worden stehen
wir bei komma auf 0 also das ist der
neue gotthard basistunnel kilometerlange
betonkabel und gleis ab und zu
ein lüftungsschacht
auf unserem fahrturm wird die
notbeleuchtung eingeschaltet  bei besserer
sicht so sieht man die schweizer
feinwerktechnik deutlich aber trotzdem
wirkt alles irgendwie unspektakulär
nur ein tunnel und doch nicht irgendein tunnel der
gotthard-basistunnel ist heute der längste
eisenbahntunnel der welt
er verbindet Rotterdam mit genua und zürich
Mailand mit dieser neuen Durchgangsader
Europa rückt näher zusammen aber
das ist teuer Jeder Meter des
Tunnels kostet mehr als 200'000 Franken
ne  xt stop sagte, dass der Raum hier einer von
vier unterirdischen Nothaltestellen ist,
wenn es ein Feuer oder eine andere Gefahr
im Tunnel gibt,
können die Passagiere zu Notplattformen evakuieren,
hier waren die grünen
Fluchttüren dann geöffnet, um Zugang zu sicheren
Evakuierungswegen zu geben, die wir nehmen werden  über einen
dieser evakuierungswege
und durch einen dunklen lüftungsschacht in
haushöhe tauchen wir an der einzigen
offenen spalte im berg auf es gibt keine
betonverkleidung keinen putz um diese offene wunde der gitarre zu verkleiden ein kleiner
see sammelt das vom berg tropfende wasser
eine treppe führt
sudhish hinunter oder ein vergessener helm eines baumeisters
schwimmt im see darüber
öffnet sich ein dunkles loch zum berg und
lässt erahnen, welche felsmassen auf dem gotthard-
basistunnel lasten fünf komma acht millionen schweizer
franken sind versenkt worden  für immer in den berg
investiert in den beiden
wartesälen der porta alvina 800 meter unterhalb
besagter rune im kanton graubünden der
tiefste bahnhof der welt
ld sollte mitten im
Gotthard-Basistunnel als Verbindung
zum alpinen Tourismusgebiet gebaut werden, heute erinnern nur noch zwei
dunkle Mulden im Berg an diesen
geplatzten Traum, sie sind versiegelt mit
schwarzen Metallstangen und
Warnschildern, die auch hinter Gittern Zutritt verbieten  ist eine
Statue der heiligen Barbara, die in einer
Nische steht sie ist die Schutzpatronin der Bergleute
und Tunnelbauer unabhängig von
Nationalität oder Religion die
Tunnelbauer ehren ihre Schutzpatronin ein
kurzer kleiner Blick danke ein Gebet oder
vielleicht gar nichts der
Festtag der heiligen Barbara wird gefeiert  jedes Jahr
am 4. Dezember wird der
Bergopfer gedacht
[Musik]
nach 800 Metern durch den Versorgungsschacht sind
wir statt Thrun angekommen und fliegen nun
bei Edo dem schneebedeckten
Denkgitarrenmassiv entgegen  was für ein panorama der
gotthard-basistunnel verläuft 2300 meter
unter diesen felsen tiefer als jeder andere
tunnel der welt und tief im
tunnel spürt man die gewalt nicht  die
natur repräsentieren diese berge jetzt
passieren wir die kantonsgrenze zwischen
graubünden
und tessin bis zum jahr 1803
hier endete die schweiz jetzt sind wir
offiziell im süden wir tauchen
wieder ab fallen in die dunkelheit
der nächste und letzte halt warum  Sie können
bittere Folie sehen, um ihre Herde zu machen, um
einen Schild oder ein Tier zu machen, um über ihren eigenen n
fonda über ihren Besitzer
oz VNC dan vitae farm ZB zu finden Z in
Adam CD Sharon bhai beta elfin tcga
exotische alte befallene Stadt unklug oder
zerstreut Elias
hoffentlich diese Ankündigung  muss
nie gespielt werden, außer als Test ist es
über das Tunnel-Sam-System zu hören
und die Ingenieure haben es gründlich getestet.
Statt der gleichen
Ansage spielten die Ingenieure
zur Abwechslung immer wieder Musik und um ihre Nerven zu beruhigen,
haben sie sich das nicht ausgesucht  Jede
Musik, aber der letzte Satz von Ludwig
van Beethovens Neunter Symphonie die
Hymne von Europa
Kilometer 57 die Berge oben - wenn
jetzt ganzjährig Schnee hinter uns liegt der
Guittard weiter  ce das größte Hindernis in
Europa ist jetzt nur noch ein Tunnel
[Musik]